when i was nine months pregnant
when you cheated on me
and if you if i wasn't pregnant i would
have [ __ ] you up so i just didn't want
to break my nails before delivery
shout out to the nails khloe kardashian
reveals how she responded to tristan
thompson cheating on her when she was
nine months pregnant with their daughter
true
isn't that crazy just a little refresher
while coco and the nba star were
together he was caught in several
cheating scandals including one with
kylie jenner's former bestie jordan
woods
you know things happen and of course i'm
sorry and apologetic as much as i can be
and another when she was expecting their
little girl
i remember when he cheated on me right
before i gave birth and i was able to
still have him in the delivery room ever
since the two have managed to amicably
raise true together everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style but my mom and my dad
were like that it took them years but my
dad would come over once a week for
family dinners and would play golf with
my stepdad and so we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be
well during the series premiere of
hulu's the kardashians the former couple
opens up about all that drama
you know it's always
such a weird
gray area because we are
such great friends yeah i think that's
so confusing to
outside people because i know how to be
a monster to you if i want to which but
you never have been which i respect
and i appreciate that
okay
i mean it's not like you've ever burned
my clothes or like slashed my cars no
i've thrown water on all your clothes if
i wasn't when i was nine months pregnant
when you cheated on me i'm not here to
play games e.t sat down with the 37 year
old good american founder and her famous
fam to talk about the new show
and chloe she seems ready to talk about
all of it well
at least for now i think for every
sister we have different boundary levels
and we all try to respect that your
boundaries are allowed to change and
mine will probably change later but i
think a lot of what is in the media is
sort of things that we feel we need to
film because it's in a way unfair to the
viewers if they don't get to see that
we've shared so much about our lives
especially the older ones we've been
doing this for so long you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
not only what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
because before you would see little
snippets of something and now i think
the episodes are um you know fuller of
content that shows the whole story
as for chloe and tristan she says
they're just friends he's one of my best
friends we get along really really well
and so it's just easy to co-parent with
him but if he had it his way they'd be a
thing
every day he tries to show me and prove
to me that he is a different person and
that i should have faith and trust him
but him and i have been through so much
together that i have a lot of
reservations you know how i feel about
you and
you know you know i want to you know get
us back together and build our family
and hopefully be able to expand our
family one day trust takes time but for
now chloe's number one priority is true
my biggest focus is being a mom to my
beautiful angel true which echoes what
she told et back in 2019. you guys have
been through so much in your life but
what are you what are you looking for
now i'm just super happy and content and
i'm focused on work and like taking care
of me my body and soul and true and i
just i'm having so much fun with her and
when i want to i will it's not some
deliberate thing that i think that hard
about
[Music]
you